I mean president Obama has been unable
to pass any legislation since his first
few years since he lost lost the house
to Republicans and there's no reason to
think that we different so America is
perilously close to you know to a failed
state here we are this rich
sophisticated country where everything
works pretty well and we have a
government that is almost incapable of
functioning and ain't going to get
better picking up on what you're saying
there i'm curious if there's any chance
that will change there has been so much
in action in washington for so long both
of these candidates talking about tax
reform say what they'd like to do to
reform our taxes do you have any sense
that they'll be greater comedy between
the White House and Congress going
forward seems unlikely yeah I mean
there's a possibility and Democrats are
almost certainly not going to take the
house but if they get close then maybe
there will be 10 or 12 Republicans who
will say ok no we're prepared what will
make will demand some concessions but we
are prepared to make some deals maybe
just possibly the trouble is the
Republicans who are likely to be left
after the loose seats are going to be
the more radical ones I mean a lot of
this has to do altima tlie with the
polarization of the public the fact that
we have Republican districts where they
don't really fear losing in the general
election they only fear being overthrown
by even crazier people in a primary so
no I don't know how this changes